I'm here with Magnus Carlson world
number one we're going to play this or
that would you rather get on a phone
call or text message text probably feel
like the answer for you is neither like
it's just usually
yes just go sunrise or sunset sunrise
winter or summer summer sauna or ice
bath both okay that that's what you do
in in Norway that you go in the sauna
and then you take an ice bath and then
you go back back in the SAA and you do
that a few times it's really nice name
your price if you have to chess box um
$10 million do you prefer to play chess
on a computer over the board or on your
phone I rarely play on my phone I I
would say I prefer to play on the
computer